some people were just there just to
march
some people was just there just for the
day out
and and some of them like me i at that
point i was i became addicted to cocaine
and alcohol which was a big part of my
marching is is getting it's like going
out with the lads for football
and that's what it became
[Music]
like so i grew up in
in uh
leeds west yorkshire
so basically i moved to
a place called beeston and i went to a
primary school but everything was okay
it wasn't until i went to the high
school things started to turn a bit sour
with
the pakistani community and the english
community the white community
which i tried to stay out of because
i played rugby and i was
i was i went to a thing called boys
brigade which is a christian
organization i was away from all
that sort of activity
so what exactly happened in high school
one day i was walking home from school i
got jumped by 12 like maybe 12 or some
of the pakistanis their anger towards
us was because of what was happening
within
school and stuff like that but i'm the
one who they took out on
so i
i thought it was just a one-off you know
like getting jumped but me as a person
i'm quite stubborn like i'm gonna stop
walking the same way home just because
that happened to me so i'd carry on
walking the same way home and it this
had happened for like two years like two
years not every day but like once or
twice a week it was it was a struggling
time for myself because
i would i didn't tell anyone so i didn't
speak about it it was just just me and
myself so
for two years i struggled with it
i was very angry
so the reason it stopped is because i
ran off
uh
i ran off from it and i i've run into my
into my house i mean mum and stepdad was
was stood there and they basically said
what's up what's up and i've gone on the
pakistanis are chasing me and then
they've told me to go outside to fight
and fight them so that's just the way i
went outside and i had to i i i beat two
of them up and the other one ran off and
then from then i got left alone
so how do you think that experience
shaped you
emotionally it did it damaged me as like
as in
my thought processes like towards that
certain people was not the same
because of the the damage that they
caused
so emotionally i would just i was all
over the place with it
and it obviously damaged me as has been
a nice person
there was there's not there weren't just
me who went through this there's loads
of people who've gone through the same
sort of uh
stuff so when you can relate to people
you tend to you follow them people and
the dolls speak about you know going on
marches and stuff like that and
i didn't know what it was for
quite quite a while but it was
known as the english defense league
and that's where it led
[Applause]
at that point i thought it was a good
thing
because when you see videos of fgm and
you see videos of
honor killing and stuff like that and
these people have got brown skin and
beards
you know you're looking and thinking
that's going to come to your country you
see you're seeing poppies you're seeing
poppies get burnt on our streets you're
seeing
you you're seeing extremism all over the
media
so for me
it was
we fought
we was we was helping
so when you first came to ideal meetings
what did you think of them what was your
experience well i had a sense of
happiness like there's some we're doing
something about it so it was
it wasn't
but
i didn't really think of of of
consequence i just thought
oh
look at look at this this is uh these
people understand what i went through so
it was relation i really there's a lot
of people that i stood and talked and
they're related they're related to what
i went through
and so for me
in my head i would just like yeah this
is this is this is good this is going to
be going to stop
this from happening to our kids or to
our our friends our family
so i looked at the 12 pakistanis the 15
pakistanis that beat me up and put it
all
onto the pakistanis without even
thinking
were you aware of the
violence that sometimes was caused by
the members of that group
well
it's it's it's when you ask that because
the only violent violence how scene was
when the antifa turned up to be honest
but
the the the that sonic violence i ever
saw like just just rowdy people that's
all that's all i ever seen rowdy people
and drunk and
stuff like that
i think after the people that i met
didn't even know why i was there uh if
you ask questions people couldn't answer
the question so it was like
some people were just there just to
march
some people was just there just for the
day out
and and some of them like me i at that
point i was i became addicted to cocaine
and alcohol which was a big part of my
marching is is getting
it's like going out with the lads for
football
and that's what it became like
what did your family think of you being
part of ideal
they didn't know
my family didn't know my mum would have
kicked me out on my house to be honest
with you i once walked in with a ukip
banner
and she told me to get out
so my mum my mum was brought up with
like different ethnic backgrounds and
that so
i couldn't tell i couldn't none of my
family knew that i was it was going
matching with the english defense league
like i wouldn't get any pictures
i wouldn't do any of that because of
because my mum because i'd have been
chucked out that's so they didn't know
was there any point where you started
seeing any flaws within the organization
yeah yeah when i started asking
questions so
two years in
so basically for two years i've just
been going and doing
and then i've just started to ask
questions like what is the quran or what
who is this muhammad you keep talking
about and
you know and asking these questions but
i was just getting
like backed off like no no no they
didn't want nobody wanted to answer my
question so i was like
i started to get feel
am i doing it for the right reasons
anymore
is this is it even working after two
years we're not we're not getting
anywhere we're just doing the same thing
over and over again
i've never met someone who could explain
what what islam was or or muslim was in
that power or what what the difference
is between the quran and and crowning
that is
i've never met someone like that even
though i ask questions but i never got
an answer
in within
within the english defense league or any
of the people around it
when you ask questions like well there's
how many million muslims here and we're
all still alive and stuff like that
uh
then they get like get people get funny
with you and you're like well
so what so what what they can't be not
like all muslims can't be just bad
you know what i mean and then you start
asking these questions that's when they
start that's when you you actually get
pushed out of the group actually to be
honest you you can feel that people are
not looking at you the same
was there a moment which you would
consider turning point
yeah there was a a turning point in my
life that
actually led me to what i where i am
today so i left the edl and then
in my state i went in i went i went in
to do
some
more i went into more crime and stuff
like that which
it's not good but i was i ended up in a
car crash the cat the car was going like
90 miles per hour and it went into like
three-part cars
but in that situation i
i broke my leg and i like metal in my
leg and i was in hospital for like three
months
i died twice in fear
and
when i got out of that and then i was in
bed for like nine months at home
i ended up reading a book
with 800 pages in it about the prophet
muhammed peace and blessing to be upon
him and
uh and i read the quran and watched the
videos
as much as i didn't want to be a muslim
after
many many research
i believed in one creator and i believed
that the prophet muhammad and jesus were
prophets of of their time so
i took i became muslim in 2015 but i
didn't tell anyone that i was going to
become muslim so
it was a shock to everyone really to be
honest all my friends uh everyone
uh my mum my dad i didn't tell anybody
what happened was that i became muslim
and in the mosque and somebody videoed
it and it went viral
and that's how everyone found out
how did you feel the first time you
walked into a mosque
anxious
scared
i'm gonna be sat with people extremists
yeah all's hearts were going through my
head when i become muslim it's the first
time i've ever been in a mosque
what i can remember anyway and
it was it was scary it was i'm sitting
with people that i don't know but don't
say they share the same culture as me
they don't share the same thought system
as me
i'm quite at that time i'm quite
arrogant i'm quite egoistic i'm i'm i'm
more i'm really really
my ego's massive i just want to be a
leader of everything i don't want to be
you know
humbled i thought that muslims were war
then white dresses
i thought that
muslims dressed like that was extremists
and
there was jihadis you're seeing people
who was your enemy
and
but the thing is when you believe
in something you have to go for it you
have to you have to take it full for
that
you know you can't keep pretending to
yourself like i will
do you think converting to islam was in
a way part of your healing journey
letting go of hate at the addiction you
had
well first of all
since i become muslim i forgive all them
pakistanis
for the sake of god
yeah i forgive all the pakistanis that
ever hurt me and damaged me that
emotions gone
secondly uh
yeah
yeah i had a really bad addiction with
cocaine and alcohol and
and in islam it's forbidden to to drink
alcohol and it's forbidden to take take
any drugs
which
when when you become muslim you submit
to to the creator
meaning
you try to follow the teachings of the
creator so
coming off alcohol and drugs has helped
me massively and
going forward it's made me into a better
person i think better
and i do things better
also praying five times a day is is is a
is also a good thing for my mentality
if i don't pray
then i struggle
but when i pray i'm everything seems to
be in order
when you look back at those years you
spend that edl how do you feel about it
now
i don't regret anything because it it
shaped who i am today
i'm
i'm a character builder so
every bit of my character is built from
from
being in the english defense league to
what i am now is like
i look at the edl and i think well look
look at the things that i've learned
from it
and and one thing i take away from it is
that i'll never go back to that no
matter what i'll never eat people just
for the just for an emotional discourse
that i've got
i think if people do have a problem or
they have an idea that islam is a bad
thing
is that coming they can come and speak
to us you know speak to us directly
speak to people because when you speak
to people who ate something you're never
going to get the answer that the actual
answer is
[Music]
so i saw people shot in the streets and
running and
seeking help
but i think those
those
i don't know if i can visualize them
those things
had an effect on me